meilleurs intervenants intervenante dans
tpm p les nommés sont
dans la catégorie award du meilleur
intervenantes et pmp de l'année les
nommés sont fabrice di vizio pour ses
répliques digne d'une commedia dell'arte
un contrat c'est que je viens en plateau
si tout le monde se souvient pas sa
toute nouvelle relative et atteste l'a
fait manifestement
elle veut mais je me foute sort chez
baxi nobel alors à béjaïa division
rubini carats pour ses punchlines de rap
plus fraîche que l'eau de son bain elle
est encore jeune mais qu'est ce que tu
sois de faire dans la vie qu'on est
allés vers les ouvertures ouais ça ça +
0 charte abattre et après on va s'amuser
nombreux dans ma tête chiba pas assumer
prend un peu de cet aveu en concurrence
beach c'est quoi ça bertrand dekkers qui
ne s'est pas encore fait au champ
lexical de tp une pda les ferralais
total shell c'est vrai j'ai dit et y
at-il au prince et diani xala total
série le mans je comprends rien de ce
que vous racontez
myriam palombes à pour ses coups de sang
qui ont fait trembler la république
on se croisait savez ce que non vie te
coûter des mois et des mois
et marco mouly pour son histoire qui a
passionné les téléspectateurs
moi je savais que j'allais me faire
arrêter ouais donc j'ai dit plus gens
dépensent vous êtes s'arrêter à temps
alors le problème c'est que moi je me
suis mis en cavale j'ai pris 8 ans donc
sur huit ans je me suis dit mot la
prison a pas m'attendre à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lamballe avait même énervé qui est passé
en
catégorie grand fan de bertrand
il a été extraordinaire à chaque fois
prévenu s'était à mourir de rire en plus
il s'en prend quand même pas mal mais à
chaque fois il rebondit rigole c'est un
mec franchement il est
naturellement on va revoir on va revoir
le dialogue de sourds entre syrie de
demain par la russie le comprend parce
que le gars qu'on ne sait rien à la
chance d'avoir toutes les infos sur
l'état de santé à de charlène on est
tous très inquiets lara sera on est
obligé de parler au conditionnel à ce
que personne n'est vraiment un monaco
c'est très particulier à doha à l'adour
à l'aco ya un problème concernant hommes
concernant charlene à la cua bertron
d'un pauvre est apparue les cheveux
rasés maintenant jours sur la toile ah
oui à laver les cheveux rasés dans
madoff comme un oeuf absolument pas
manquer oui quoi avec un oui apple à
britney est là mais
les filles à la totale non mais c'est
vrai j'ai dit il ya t-il ou princesse
diana total série le mans je comprends
rien parce que vous raconte
[Applaudissements]
et vous retrouvez d'ailleurs bertrand
déclare d'entrée péter bichsel samedi
avec d'ailleurs des bords à abidjan pour
la dernière de la saison présentée par
mon camarade matthieu delormeau on va
revoir quand même si on va revoir quand
même division
cette
année l'invité qui passe son temps à
partir du plateau
jamais
regardé tente vaille contrat c'est que
je viens en plateau si tout le monde se
soumet pas sa toute nouvelle relative
est un test l'a fait manifestement
elle est là mais elle veut mais je m'en
fous de ça chez baxi nommer un gala
labège visio via une loi monsieur
divisia pas encore un arrêt division
mais rassurez vous présente aussi la
force de loi sa prime de mensonge donc
fabrice tu veux quitter plateau mais moi
je crois qu'on est blessé lockheed et
platon et socrate enceinte à cet endroit
mais reçoit la famille a des fois ci
chez jeanneau fondamentale vous avez
raison fabrice
il est comme déjà mis pour partir mais
la bible si on lui remit les deux sont
de sa campagne ou du cheval il a échoué
le même blouson plus qu'avant merdé
voulez bien vous monsieur division moi
je trouve ça un personnage avec lui on
sait qu'il va se passer quelque chose ce
plateau c'est ça qui manque parfois la
dérision c'est la paix dans ces coupes
et enregistrer tout est préparé on sait
déjà ce que les gens ont dû lui se passe
toujours quelque chose me fait penser à
gargamel les schtroumpfs la
coupe pas exactement pareil on va revoir
la numéro un mondiale s'est mis un
ballon bas leur catégorie d'âge ils ont
tout pété les plombs et à s'insurger
contre le gouvernement et contre le
vaccin à tel point que ça m'a un peu
agacé je dois le dire on s'agace et tout
le monde mais moi je lui ai dit et je
n'ai fait pleurer je m'en excuse je suis
désolé cela dit il ya donc des moments
voilà comme d'aisé audiard voilà voilà
regardez déjà
droite par les
côtés toi et couiza et la droite pourrir
la vie des gens riton faut enlever les
allées les indemnités chômage aux jambes
elle today le pape
c'est d'une violence incroyable et vous
vous vous êtes là en train de le débat
parce qu'il a eu un peu atypique est
venu lire vous savez ce que nous on vit
que depuis des mois et des mois
ben laden
[Applaudissements]
là il parlait de votre coupe de cheveux
je crois nous suce alors oui parce que
c'est un accident kevin eyres pendant là
j'ai essayé alors la couleur j'ai fait
plonger fait violer violée c'était par
extraits violée oui ça va
gueuler hausse est de 6 c'est
dégueulasse ça c'était assez souvent de
l'académie des neuf l'étaient pas
surtout quand on se met bien quand même
là pour le doublé mais du coup vous avez
tourné une pub comme ça donc ça passe
tous les jours ou très récemment n'ont
pas traîné la pub c'est sur une saison
enfin quelques mois ça dure on
renouvelle le contrat
ouais mais renouvelle la couleur ou la
cible